natural killer cells are the cold blood  killers in the immune system they engage  with any cells and intend to kill them  but all the cells has class 1 MHC which  allows this particular cell to disengage  but in certain cases where class 1 MHC  is not there  NK cells would intend to kill them and  that what happens in the viral infection  many viruses down regulate class 1 MHC  molecule so obviously with the down  regulation of class 1 MHC the cd8  positive T cell would disengage but NK  cell would be the Fail-Safe mechanism it  would kill those infected cell and save  us from the virus  now NK cell therapy is really important  because NK cell plays vital role  to recognize and eliminate tumor cells  NK cell therapy is 73 percent efficient  watch more watch the full video to know  more